bella is energetic
and she wants to be everyone's friend
this husky cross german shepherd is
looking for a new home and she's in luck
i believe in second chances and there
are so many dogs out there who just need
that second chance um
take bella for example i mean you know
she uh had a loving home they just
couldn't look after her anymore so um
it's not her fault and she deserves the
love that any dog can get
charities are dealing with the fallout
from pet ownership rocketing during
lockdown
they want more people to consider taking
on abandoned dogs rather than buying
puppies
before the pandemic the average price of
a dog in the uk was 876
pounds that rose to 2
237 pounds in march 2021
but by the summer that was down to
1873 pounds and it continues to fall
some charities are worried that as
demand and prices go down the more
callous breeders could find themselves
with puppies that they can't turn a
profit on
and they could dump them
the rspca said that over christmas they
rescued 29
more dogs and other animals than the
previous year
this charity in worcestershire thinks
the cost of living crisis is also having
an impact we're seeing a lot of people
who have lost their jobs through
covenant and can't afford the animals
anymore we're getting a lot of animals
come in who aren't very well and because
the owners can't afford the vet care
and we are definitely seeing people who
have taken on dogs during the pandemic
are now going back to work don't have
the time for them anymore
the shelter is hopeful they found
someone to give percy the time he needs
but others are waiting and they're
worried there'll be many more to come
lisa dowd sky news malvin